there is more turbulence for Boeing as
it reels from two deadly crashes of its
737 max jets in Ethiopia and Indonesia
Indonesia's national airline has
submitted paperwork seeking the
cancellation of a multi-billion dollar
order for nearly 50 737 max Jets Kris
Van Cleave says it could be just the
first wave of what some are calling a
financial tsunami for Boeing the
cancellation of the roughly five billion
dollar order is the latest fallout for
Boeing following the two 737 max crashes
that killed 346 people it presents a
huge threat to Boeing's bottom line the
737 max is estimated to account for one
third of Boeing's total revenue over the
next five years and the company has lost
14% of its stock price since the
Ethiopian air crash thirteen days ago
this is the type of thing that is a
financial tsunami if Boeing loses orders
it is billions of dollars potentially at
risk maybe tens or more but in fairness
we have only seen one airline announced
that it plans to cancel its airport's
737 max orders aviation industry analyst
Henry Hart de Velde says Boeing's
workforce could be impacted if other
airline's follow suit as with any
business when Boeing loses an order it's
going to lose revenue and so depending
on the number of orders that could get
cancelled that could have an impact not
only on Boeing's top-line revenue and
their profits but on their workers max
operator Norwegian is seeking
compensation from Boeing for having its
planes grounded the grounding is
estimated to cost airlines about 150
thousand dollars per day per plane
Boeing shelled out 500 million to
Airlines after grounding the 787 for
three months in 2013 there is no
question that this aircraft was rushed
to market lawyer Steve marks is suing
Boeing on behalf of families of 20
people killed in october's Lyon air
crash he believes the rush to catch up
to rival Airbus in 2015 led to design
mistakes in the max that turned deadly
the certification process was abused in
this case the regulator's did not do
their job
Boeing took advantage of it this weekend
American
lines pilots will test Boeing's software
fix for the 737 max for CBS this morning
Saturday Kris Van Cleave Washington